قبل لحظات دمرت غارة جوية إسرائيلية
مبنى من 12 طابقًا في
غزة كان يضم العديد من المنافذ الإخبارية
بما في ذلك الصحافة المرتبطة والجزيرة
نعم ، وكانت الشقق السكنية
أيضًا في ذلك المبنى الذي
أنشأته قناة سي إن إن ، نيك روبرتسون ينضم إلينا الآن من
إسرائيل بالقرب من حدود غزة.
يقول إنه تم ارتداؤه للإخلاء
قبل حوالي ساعة من حدوث ذلك الإضراب ،
ما الذي تعلمته ،
حسنًا ، يقول حماس إنهم
سينتقمون يقولون إنهم
سينتقمون من
تل أبيب ، وهذا تحذير
يوجهونه إلى السكان أه  في تلك المنطقة
المحيطة بتل أبيب يقولون
بسبب استهداف ذلك
المبنى الذي استخدمته وسائل الإعلام من قبل
قناة الجزيرة من قبل الصحافة المرتبطة بها ،
فإن قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية تقول
إن البناء
لم يقتصر على مؤسسات إعلامية أه
وشقق عادية ، بل كان يضم أيضًا شققًا سكنية.
منشآت استخبارات عسكرية
تديرها
وحدات استخبارات عسكرية تابعة لحماس ،
لذلك تقول قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
أنها كانت مشروعة  الهدف ماتي أنه تم توجيه
تحذير
للجميع في ذلك المبنى
للخروج ولهذا السبب تم استهدافه
، وكما كنا عندما كنا
نأتي على الهواء هناك ، كان بإمكاني سماع
صوت اعتراض صواريخ القبة الحديدية التي
تحاول اعتراض الصواريخ
القادمة  من غزة أن الصواريخ
التي
وعدت حماس بإطلاقها باتجاه تل
أبيب غير واضح ،
لكن هذا العصر أدى بالتأكيد إلى
تصعيد التوتر إلى حماس
ونعلم بالفعل اليوم أن
حماس
أطلقت صواريخ في منطقة تل أبيب ،
وانطلقت صفارات الإنذار في وقت سابق اليوم مرتين
و  قُتل رجل يبلغ من العمر 50 عامًا
في أحد الشوارع هناك في إحدى البلدات الصغيرة
خارج تل أبيب